[Music]
2020 was a year during which the country
reckoned with racial injustice
after the killing of george floyd calls
for police reform came from across the
country
including rethinking the role of police
in responding
to mental health crises lilia luciano
introduces us to a crisis response team
that's working
in partnership with police in eugene
oregon when you call 9-1-1 you don't
always get the police
if it's a mental health crisis you'll
get cahoots
for more than 30 years cahoots which
stands for crisis assistance helping out
on the streets
has been serving communities in central
oregon there's a guy on river road who i
think would benefit from
having cahoots come visit him responding
to a fifth of all 9-1-1
calls with unarmed crisis workers and
emts
instead of armed police officers we
respond in teams of two
to non-violent and non-criminal
crises so when people call 9-1-1
sometimes calls go to police
sometimes go to cahoots yes personally
having lost my father during a police
encounter it matters to me that
people feel as though there's an option
for them in the public safety system
that can support them through what
they're going through
crisis workers train for at least 500
hours on crisis intervention
for the police officers they partner
with that number
is closer to 40. i have a van full of
medical gear and clothes when we have it
and snacks i also can bring folks to a
crisis center
or somewhere to get a shower somewhere
to sober up for a little while so i have
a really large toolbox
when police show up they have the
hospital and they have the jail
more than a thousand people have been
shot and killed by police in the last
year
according to a washington post database
and one in four of those fatal police
shootings
involve a person with mental illness
according to the national alliance on
mental illness
angela kimball runs advocacy there
people are starting to rethink
a police response to mental health
crises
what do you take the concept of
defunding police to me
we take the concept of defunding police
to really be more about
investing in community resources that
really works to divert people from law
enforcement involvement
so we're talking about things like
crisis hotlines
mobile crisis response cahoots saves the
communities it serves an
estimated 22.5 million dollars annually
and local police say they welcome the
efforts now more than ever
i think the pandemic has caused a lot of
anxiety in the community
and a lot of the unknowns and people who
maybe initially didn't have glaring
mental health issues
those issues started to rise to the top
in the community and how do the police
officers
respond i mean do they feel threatened
like their job is
at risk just the opposite what cops want
to do is stop
crime catch criminal if a robbery
assault
burglary occurs we can respond to that
instead of being stuck on a call in
which we're
dealing with mental health issues he
says it lets cops be cops again
there's less burnout less overtime for
the agency and a safer community
for cbs this morning saturday luciano
eugene oregon so many things jump out on
that the hours of training
the need to work in conjunction with
each other and just the idea that you
have to rethink
how we are responding in communities
yeah the need to just think differently
yeah i remember this came up when i
covered daniel pruitt in rochester
because there were concerns about his
mental state he had been at a hospital
earlier
for that very reason and now you have
cities that are looking more seriously
at
how you can effectively police those
issues and then
you you saw on the report it even saves
money right